the job of product management on all
levels is be able to connect the dots
for people and make them excited and
kind of see the light about something
and this that's just amazing to me it's
an amazing thing
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright xl
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today we are with opher geyer the vp of
productive hunters a soc platform which
aims to disrupt the s-i-e-m category his
role includes overseeing all aspects of
product vision strategy road map and
user experience collaborating with
leaders across the company to make the
vision a reality alpha recently returned
to israel after spending six years in
san francisco and prior to hunters offer
managed a variety of cyber security
product lines and teams at exa beam and
imperva
before transitioning into product he was
a security researcher at in capsula and
an idf intelligence officer
thank you so much for joining me
um you know it's such an awesome career
trajectory
from spending time as a captain in the
idf and some in some of the most
incredible places within the
intelligence units to being a senior
product manager at imperva to exit beam
and today vice president of product at
series c company hunters um really one
of the greatest prides in the israeli
tech scene is been making a lot of buzz
lately and and i'm excited to sort of
understand
your positioning better in in the
product sphere and what that means to
you
a little bit about your journey within
product abroad and in israel and perhaps
some of the differences but then
it just as interestingly product within
security and what is that like and so
thank you very much for joining me today
thank you for having me so yeah i i
started off when i when i kind of left
the military i was having fun in the
military it's always interesting it's
intelligence work it's very sexy but i
was like i want to see what's out there
well don't wait i don't like inertia i
really like to kind of move away from my
comfort zone as much as possible over
time kind of you can see that with every
step that i kind of took so i was like
let me see what's out there i joined a
company called encapsula um
early pretty early on 30-something
employees
uh things that we today call product-led
growth so a sas
uh cloud platform and in 2013 was kind
of novel uh i joined there as a security
researcher um
i was very enthusiastic about doing some
you know in the wild defending versus
intelligence awards it's usually on the
more offending side
um
and we're kind of really hitting amazing
product market fit what i know today to
be amazing product markets fit and kind
of exploded
and i we were small enough for me to get
kind of good kind of optics into okay
this is a company making a lot of
aggressive decisions
uh they work really well and
understanding kind of oh there's a
business side and that kind of really
intrigued me
after a couple years i kind of moved
into
um
our senior roles and when i relocated
shortly after i kind of moved into
product management having this
conversation with my
my managers at the time i really fell in
love with the business side right
um
so
yeah so i moved to the business side i
wanted to do more than just security
research yeah
so what what really was this what
made this shift for you because you're
spending so much time
as as a senior researcher really and and
you know spending seven years in the in
the in the idf in in some of the most
intensive research oriented groups you
really learn you know the the art of
researching and and deep tech and so
what really made you say okay actually i
want to take now what i learned but
explore this in in more of a business
context how how did that happen
i i loved security research i feel i'm
still kind of being in touch with a lot
of security groups and i have a lot of
people in in proper security research in
my life
but i felt like i wanted to create
bigger impact
for the company that i'm part of
security research is is one part of it
and i always felt like there's some
ceiling in the type of impact you can do
when only looking super deep in one area
and product really gave me that ability
to drive a lot more impact also felt
like i have some sort of
some sort of advantage because i am able
to talk security and talk business and
talk to customers and kind of
be that
uh focal point between everybody uh so i
feel like this is something i can do
uh do well and have fun doing
right okay so and so looking back now
many years later are you able to sort of
distill
what what was it that that captured
that captured you so now that you've
been doing this for for quite some time
and you've held numerous positions is it
still this
is it still what you thought when you
transitioned into this world i i didn't
know any like
if you haven't done product management
before it's very different than what it
is in practice
but what i really love what i really
enjoy is these moments of absolute
clarity when something just clicks
you're able to crack something like okay
this is where the market is going this
is what customers don't understand or
this is what our engineering doesn't get
and i'm able to
connect dots for other people
and then they now understand something
they have and this is this is how i see
the job of product management on all
levels is be able to connect the dots
for people and make them excited and
kind of see the light about something
and this that's just amazing to me it's
an amazing feeling
and so
specifically for diving into product
within
security
um whether it's in the world of hunters
or imperva
is that is that dramatically different
than
product
at other perhaps verticals is there
different thinking that needs to take
place different experience that one
needs to have
yeah definitely so i think in two
aspects it's very different right so
one aspect is the type of expectation
that uh customers or users have from a
security product they usually think of
something that super tech savvy
complicated services heavy
um
and that's the type of persona that they
think about right it's also the persona
itself is super technical that's how
they perceive it
but what i have come to realize is
security is just lagging behind just the
rest of the product world and just
making things simple and easy to use
so
although we're not kind of b2c product
managers that keep thinking about small
features that delight the users
we're definitely not doing a great job
in a lot of products to just make the
product easy
and the products that are able to make
the job easy for that customer or the
ones that win it doesn't matter if you
have some amazing engine that you
developed
if your customer is unable to take
advantage of it because it's just too
complicated and it's not easy to consume
i think this is and here's where we sort
of
this is where we sort of divert from
perhaps the classical
literature on on research and security
right because in researchers you would
say well my role is to find the most
meaningful insights with whatever crazy
technology i'm building and really
highly trained people will make use of
this of this engine but you're saying
wait the world works a little bit
differently
and we have to actually account for that
yeah i use had the conversation with
with a friend of mine and you say you
know when i was a researcher and he was
one of the top researchers in some
company and he said i thought that the
most exciting thing and most important
thing for security company is to be able
to find zero days right and if you don't
find zero days in water what is it that
you're doing
and then
i i joined here i'm looking at it i'm
working on a product and i was like
we're at stage zero
stage one stage three and zero days is
like some something that's over the
horizon for most customers they're not
even getting started with a lot of their
security needs right that's kind of like
aha moment for a lot of security
researchers that kind of
start work working more with product and
not just finding the bad guys in the
most
in the coolest way
incredible and so if you're looking
today at
sort of bridging this gap and
you as a researcher you as a user and at
the end is a product manager bridging
the gap between the world and
research
right
how do you balance that and sort of how
do you know to prioritize
all all this big you know mess together
into one coherent strategy of this is
how we should do things and and and
especially in a place where you have a
lot of other people that are competing
with you for speed for agility for for
ease of use
exactly so
i think our
what we look at is looking at what our
customers trying to achieve and then
figuring out what's the best way to help
them achieve that in the easiest way in
the most predictable way
customers especially in the security
space
they really want someone they're looking
for kind of a sherpa to help them
and say i know what the security threat
is that you're trying to tackle
here's what it is and i have the recipe
to how to tackle it and if you follow
these simple rules and use this simple
platform you're able to protect against
these threads instead of saying listen
there's a lot of things you can do with
the platform so here's a bunch of stuff
and you can figure it out and we can use
services and
this very vague approach to security
right
telling you everything but the kitchen
sink kind of and i'm not very kind of
let's focus on what matters the most to
you
customer and have a very clear way to to
achieve
to to kind of mitigate this this risk
this is this is your top risk let's
mitigate that risk for you and have it
in a very prescriptive manner
i think that is a very honest candid
approach to security versus having a
little bit of everything but really
you're not covering
most of your attack surface it's about
looking at your attack surface and then
figuring out how do i prioritize and
what assurance do i really have that i'm
covering something
yeah
so i'd love to
sort of pick your brain on this because
you would assume
that
there are some fields in the world that
are going to stay
with high friction and high barrier to
entry where really you do need some
expertise in order to deal with it right
for example in if you want to be a
doctor you still have to study for i
don't know seven or eight years in order
to treat patients but it almost feels
like today's cyber security platforms
are in are making it easier for people
to have less experience
be able to resolve more within their
organizations and i understand that
perhaps that is coming is because of a
lack of
experienced people and so companies have
to adapt and therefore
products after that is this the right
way to go about this do you think that
that we should be building products that
make it simpler rather than perhaps
empowering the experts within
organizations
i think it's about a point but i do
think that most products out there today
they just add another thing to look at
not necessarily make that thing simpler
so we now have a tank on let's say
kubernetes
or lambda functions or whatever right
and now i have another thing
to look at
um that covers yet another attack
surface which is great it's important to
have that
but someone needs to help
the underlying the end customer which is
one team eventually that needs to cover
all these different things that are
changing and say right hey i'm here to
help and figure out out of all these
different signals all these different
things here's what it is
because like he said it's it's very hard
for that person to be an expert
that person that's that's the the
bottleneck today right
and nobody can be an expert on so many
fields in security i was a researcher i
was pretty good in application security
i'm not an expert at endpoint security
you asked me to to reverse engineer
malware i don't know how to do that i'm
pretty good with world application
security and ddos i can talk about that
probably for a few hours right most
security people they have some scope
where they're the expert on and the
problem is
you can't just say oh you know as a
company we're gonna focus on web
application security because big
companies they have everything right so
how can we take that everything
and distill it to something that's
consumable by the average joe
um
or jan in a sock i think that's that's
that's an amazing challenge to look at
because that really moves the needle for
companies right
i i love that understanding because
you're right i mean at the end
it's expanding
in a ridiculous way and and it
internal teams within organizations
can't possibly keep up with everything
new that's going on and so um even even
if what i said before has some ground to
it it's still lacking this very
fundamental idea that
you know every day there's new things
that are popping up that we just have
that we just don't have visibility into
and we
necessarily don't have the capacity to
deal with
you had a unique experience as well
venturing out and doing product
management
back in back in california doing it back
in israel the startup nation ecosystem
obviously is is growing and product
is that i think there's an agreement
that product is still something that you
know we're developing a skill for
it's still a work in progress
how do you see it you've experienced you
know both sides now
what were some of your impressions
yeah the it's it's
it's very interesting to kind of i've
been like been back for six months now
and i'm looking at different things and
culturally in product that are different
so
for example israelis they we have a huge
tendency to to go directly to solutions
and we don't really learn to to talk
about the problem and really the still
we're like okay let's go go go go go go
go
but in the product our job first and
foremost is to say stop why why why why
why an israelis are go go go go go so
that kind of creates a a interesting
kind of not conflict but contradiction
or
attention there um another thing is
um israelis um because of the cultural
differences sometimes most companies
most bdd software companies the big
business it's in north america right
and when they talk to customers they
don't pick up on the nuance of what the
customer is actually telling you
right so they say oh they we had a great
conversation
right
he had an okay conversation or maybe he
was not very good at all they were not
happy they're not gonna tell you you
know to your face like an israeli right
so you it's it's a combination of slight
confirmation bias but also cultural
differences are very interesting that
now that i talk to a customer and look
at around the room and sometimes like
that's not let's listen to what we're
being told here because that's not
necessarily they're not necessarily
happy or they're very happy
um but they truly are happy and here's
here's how we can how we can tell right
no you know it almost feels like an
an understanding like this can't come
from
from a textbook or from mentorship or
from or from simply experiencing it in
israel i mean it kind of feels like you
you sort of have to
live through those experiences get those
sort of
uh you get that friction yourself
in order to have that
ability to to even notice it right
yeah exactly and sometimes people are
here listen you have experienced pms in
israel that have experienced it but they
don't understand maybe why they will say
you know it's it's uh
you know this customer was annoying they
told me one thing but sometimes but it's
not it's just cultural differences they
but you if you live it if you if you
live in the us and it surrounds you like
okay um there's just other are there
cues to to pick up on uh versus an
israeli that's it it's not really
picking up you know it's just like it's
in your face
um yeah and i think that i you know it's
conversation i've been having a lot
lately with different people about you
know giving giving more credit to
to these cultural differences
and not assuming that one culture
perhaps is
is the is the right one or the better
one in terms of these communication
because at the end
um
that that just leads to points of
failure right i mean you have there's
there's a system that is very
complicated that's built on hundreds of
years of of you know capitalism and
innovation
there's a reason why the country why you
know this country succeeds in what it
does and there's also a reason why
israel succeeds in what it does and
people who are able to merge
sounds like they have sort of a
superpower right
yeah exactly exactly and you need to
find the right altitude for the right
phase of your company right whatever
works for you is a 10 person company me
probably doesn't work for 50 probably
doesn't work for 150 right
and 500 not a lot of com not a lot of
israeli companies really uh are doing
well at above 500 right you can see that
a lot of execs come start pouring in
from
uh from the us sometimes to to bridge up
culture
of do you miss researching do you miss
sitting down for days and weeks and
sort of slamming your head on the table
and trying to figure out
you know
what is happening
i i don't miss that part i sometimes
miss just having the level of kind of
scientific clarity that i cracked
something because pm is a lot of kind of
experience and
you're working with a lot of unknowns
and you're trying to build your company
and make it grow right in research it's
very kind of there's a good dichotomy
like i was able to to to address that
issue i was able to crack that very kind
of clear cut and sometimes it's just it
makes it easy it's a lot less of a
mental toll right it's like i know i
fixed it it's 100 right p.m you can make
a decision
and you have a good gut feeling but
it it's working this week it's working
that week third week oh that actually
we're
we're missing or we're not missing okay
fourth week it's always kind of an up
and down
so it might be fun to kind of have
something that's a bit like okay i'm
done for the day i i know exactly what i
need pm is always like open-ended it's
it's part of staying out of the comfort
zone that i like so much but sometimes
you just want to you know take a rest
but
i love it
it it it sounds incredible and i and and
personally it sounds very fulfilling to
be able to hold both pieces of the
puzzle and and to both have that
scientific capacity
but also the ability to to lead product
teams and lead visions of how to take
these scientific understandings
translate them to the real world make a
business impact understand culturally
how to do that globally
and grow that experience over time which
sounds okay just a fascinating journey
so alpha thank you so much for this time
and for your for your energy and for
your impact on our ecosystem and uh best
of luck with the with hunters and stay
safe and stay healthy
thank you so much for having me was a
blast
take care thank you
[Music]